okay
[Music]
I turned into a teenage girl
according to Jenna Ortega it wasn't easy
being Wednesday Adams yeah in a recent q
a with Netflix Jenna revealed that along
with taking fencing and cello lessons
the filming scheduled for Wednesday
almost left her at her breaking point
but it was shoot you know show up to set
two hours early do the 12 14 hour day
then go home and then get on a zoom and
have whatever lesson that I had or had
whatever cello lesson or I would choke
to my apartment and My Cello teacher was
already waiting for me it was like that
sort of thing where it was just
constantly going then if you could on a
weekend if we weren't shooting the sixth
day that week it was the all right well
then we'll get your lessons in on that
day if you couldn't do it tonight you
know having only started cello lessons a
couple months before shooting the series
in Romania Jenna shared that the painted
black number was the hardest to master I
would say that the first piece that I
play Paint It Black on the cello Danny
Elfman score I had not touched a cello
until about two months prior and the
score that Danny wrote wrote I got maybe
two weeks before we shot it so I didn't
get to practice with my first cello
teacher I had a practice with the second
Romanian cello teacher so that was
already weird switching teachers but
also the piece is made for two cellos
and not one so I have to pretend like
I'm playing it I'm
I had I didn't know where my hands were
even supposed to go and then I had to
pretend like I knew what I I could make
two cello sounds come out of one cello
which was ridiculous so I did not get
any sleep I pulled my hair out there's
so many FaceTime calls that my dad
answered of me hysterically crying Jenna
also revealed that despite her wanting
to film as much as she could as
Wednesday time constraints got in the
way towards the end of their eight-month
shoot he started running out of time
because Wednesdays and pretty much every
scene so they're towards like as the
episodes go on they had to start using
stunt doubles or occasionally cello
double if they didn't have time to get
hands but I was very adamant about
being as well prepared as possible
because I wanted them to be able to use
myself because that's so much more
believable if you see her face in the
pressure right as for what's in store
for Wednesday and season two I know
nothing I think I'm supposed to have a
maybe a call in like a week or two I
just don't think it's like let me know
what's going on but yeah I think the
writer's room I think is very fresh they
just started last month so
what do you hope to see from Wednesday
when the show returns uh naturally I
thought that the show was gonna be a bit
more early and a bit more into the
horror aspect
um so that would be interesting I don't
want to scare away young viewers but at
the same time it could be interesting
I don't want to see uh last season they
kind of tried to put Wednesday in a bit
of a love triangle which that was like a
weird thing to justify and I don't think
that that's natural for her so I feel
like I would rather just focus on her
and her experience as a teenager rather
than I don't know I just don't I don't
want things to become romantic because
that's always in my opinion the most
boring part of a show